je ne veux pas me réveiller dans 4 ans
et me dire oh non je ne reconnais pas la
personne que je suis devenu
j'ai l'immense honneur de vous présenter
la Première Dame des
-Unis
la première dame doit être une femme
très particulière
hors de question que tu sois dans les
coulisses à manier le gouvernail ils
veulent faire de moi une espèce de
Martinoire ce choix serais mon équipe et
les causes que je t'ai fondé on est
d'accord
tu savais ce qui t'attendait tu m'as
caché tes ambitions politiques
je serai là mais je resterai moi-même
ne me repoussez pas je suis votre épouse
pas l'une de vos petites amies
vous êtes les poux d'une femme qui pense
par elle-même
et qui mène sa propre vie
[Musique]
ces messieurs pensent que je ferais
mieux de me taire c'est votre chance
d'influencer l'histoire je suis morte de
peur pour mes filles je ne pouvais pas
devoir te détruire comme ça
j'ai fait tout ce qu'on attendait de moi
tout le monde nous juge tout le temps
ils n'auront qu'à essayer de me mettre
dehors
mais ils ne feront pas de moi quelqu'un
que je ne suis pas
[Musique]